we're now going to explore one of the
most fundamental reactions in organic
chemistry and first let's look at what
what are the things that are going to
react so over here I have a hydroxide
anion it has a negative 1 charge and
that negative 1 charge comes from the
fact that oxygen is neutral if it has
six valence electrons but this has one
two three four five six plus plus half
of this bond with hydrogen so you could
think of that as another electron or
it's it's sharing it's it's got half of
these two so that's another electron
which gives it a negative one charge now
this right over here it has one carbon I
guess you could say it in its backbone
so you would use it's it's a methane and
it has a group right over here
consisting of bromine so this is bromo
this is bromo methane so let's think a
little bit about what might happen under
the right conditions so this hydroxide
anion we've already gone over the fact
that you can kind of view it as having
an extra electron which gives us this
negative charge well if you have a
negative charge anion like this it will
be attracted to positive things and one
example of a positive thing is a nucleus
and so in this reaction we are going to
refer to this hydroxide anion as the
nucleophile nucleophile file literally
refers to things that something likes
this thing likes it's a nucleus lover I
guess you could say and so it might want
to it might want to share maybe a pair
of an electron a pair of electrons with
a nucleus now over here I have this
bromo group in the bromomethane and
bromine is quite electronegative it is
more electronegative than carbon so even
in this bond we have two electrons in
this bond right over here bromine is
gonna hog the electrons a little bit
more than carbon and also
electronegativity says that if this bond
were to break it's more likely that this
pair the pair that's in this bond is
going to go to the bromine then it's
going to go to the car
so the way that this reaction works and
it's really kind of happening in one
step and this is key to the name of this
reaction as we'll see in a second is
that this nucleophile right over here
might say hey let me share I got this
extra charge let me share some of that
charge with a nucleus in this case in
this case the carbon drive like this in
this case the carbon so it would share
this pair which would form a bond a
carbon would have half of the pair
oxygen would have half of the pair so it
would share this pair it would share
this pair with carbon now if carbon is
now sharing half of this it's getting
it's essentially kind of getting half an
elector it's getting an electron it
doesn't need this electron which bromine
is already hogging a little bit and so
bromine would take this entire pair back
whenever we draw full arrows like this
just normal arrows that you're used to
seeing it's referring to the action of
pairs so this whole pair is going to
bromine this pair right over here is now
going to be shared with the carbon it's
going to form a bond with the carbon so
when we do both of these steps after
both of these steps it would look like
this it would look like this let me draw
my bromine first which is now going to
become a bromide anion so bromine one
two three four five six one two three
four five six and now it gets both of
these electrons both of these electrons
from this from this bond so it has both
of those electrons right over there
now this will have a negative one charge
how do we know that well bromine is
pause is bromine is neutral when it has
seven valence electrons this thing now
has eight so this now has a that has a
negative charge
now let's thinking let's think about
what happens to all of this business so
let me draw up my carbon first my carbon
now let me draw this hydrogen that's
popping out so this hydrogen that's
popping out let me draw it like that so
that's the bond trying to show that it's
popping out of the page so that's that
hydrogen I just made them different
colors so we can keep track of the
different hydrogen's then the hydrogen
that's going into the page that's that
one right over there and you
have this hydrogen that's going up so
that hydrogen right over there
and now the hydroxide anion has bonded
to this carbon now it's it'll be a
hydroxyl group so this thing has now
bonded so let me draw the bond in the
color of these two electrons it has now
bonded so this those two electrons now
make up this blurr this bond right over
here and now we have our oxygen but with
one those two these two right over here
these two right over here and then the
bond to the hydrogen now what just
happened here the oxygen is now neutral
why is it neutral it has one two three
four and then it has half of this bond
so you could view that as an electron or
the equivalent of electron charge and
then it has half of this bond so it has
the electron charge equivalent of six
valence electrons which makes oxygen
neutral and now bromine is negative so
one way to think about is that the
negative charge has been transferred to
the bromine in this reaction now in this
reaction bromine has left and that's why
we call this the leaving group we call
this right over here the leaving group
the leaving group the leaving group of
the reaction this thing is right over
here is the thing that is going to leave
that is the leaving group now the other
thing that you might find interesting it
looks like kind of this hydroxide anion
some people even say attacked this
bromomethane the bromomethane left the
hydroxide anion the hydroxide anti the
the bromine left not the bromomethane
left attract the bromo attacked the
bromomethane the bromine left so in some
ways you'd say that there's really two
reactants over here you have the
hydroxide anion and have you have the
bromide anion and this carbon right over
here with the hydrogen's this was kind
of the thing that just to somebody
facilitated the reaction that you know
this thing bumped into it and attached
and then this thing left and so in this
context we would call the carbon with
the three hydrogen's we would call this
the substrate the substrate substrate
now what should we call this reaction
well one way to think about it is we
substituted to this bromo
group with a hydroxyl group so it might
make sense to call this a substitution
reaction substitution has occurred
substitution has occurred now what did
we substitute with well we substituted
with a nucleophile we substituted with a
nucleophile and how many reactants were
involved in the rate-determining step
and I know that might not make a lot of
sense to you but this had essentially
one into one determining step this had
to want to bump in the right way and
this would want to have to leave right
at the same time in order for this or
roughly the same time in order for this
reaction to occur so this reactant and
this reactant were involved in figuring
out well how fast is this reaction going
to happen and we're going to see future
reactions where you don't have both
react both reactants involved in the
rate-determining step will see only one
reactant involved in the
rate-determining step but i'll
registrate this right over here to true
reactants in rate determining step
there's a garbage truck outside I think
the garbage truck has left now safe to
resume so we were saying there are two
reactants involved in the rate in the
rate determining determining Manning
step and so the shorthand for this
reaction is to call it an SN sn2
reaction an sn2 reaction
it's substitution with the nucleophile
where both reactants are involved in the
rate determining step